gravity falls a show
that we watch once a week with an
irregular day of when to upload it
is it tuesday is it wednesday is it
thursday doesn't matter it's any day but
it'll come it'll fall on you at the
right time hit that like button if that
upsets you subscribe and click that
notification bell you're especially
going to want to do that in this case
also full length watch along as we sync
up with the time code for gf or on our
patreon page over there we cover many
shows with the same tier you get the
option for highlights and watch along
included lastly thanks to the boys over
at prepper who told me exclusively they
are not going to celebrate christmas or
new year's solely so they could edit for
us and they will not get paid holiday or
overtime let's get into it
[Music]
examine the evidence and this is
obviously an accident quack quack
quack quack quack
that duck is a genius eh it's easier to
find clues when you're that close to the
ground
you'll never guess where i found buried
treasure buried hey i was gonna say that
so i was cleaning up when i found the
secret door hidden behind the wallpaper
let's do this
bonkers creepy
what it's like that twilight zone
episode hello
it's just me your grunkle stan
[Laughter]
[Music]
grunkle standing you guys in the
comments keep saying that
it's just just to get like something
something
something
political
behold the gravity falls wax museum it
was one of our most popular attractions
before i forgot all about it i got them
all genghis khan sherlock holmes some
kind of i don't know gobbling man
oh poor larry my personal favorite wax
abraham lincoln oh
don't worry grunkle stan i'll make you a
new wax figure from all this old wax
what do you think of my wax figure idea
she's part fairy princess and part horse
fairy princess gross
oh from real life like a waffle with big
arms
i want it else like like someone in your
family kids have you seen my pants
has anyone seen my pants
[Music]
i think
it needs more glitter
i found my pants but now i'm missing my
what do you think
i think the wax museum's back in
business
max museums are fun yeah
oh i want a corn dog i can't believe
this many people showed up i know right
you all know me folks town darling
missed a mystery please ladies control
yourselves
oh
my kind of woman around
but enough about me
behold
me
thank you for coming i made this
sculpture with my own two hands it's
covered in my blood sweat oh my god
your flyers promised free pizza with
admission to this event is this true
that's what i hate
that was a typo good night everyone
all just water free pizza
[Music]
i think that went well
no you're delusional well doctor it
seems you've really
quacked the
ah case duck well i'm gonna use the john
oh no
no
wax stan he's been
murdered
oh
sure duck homes
[Laughter]
this case is unsolvable what you know i
could help if you want he's really good
city boy thinks he's going to solve a
mystery with his fancy computer phone
steve is going to fit an entire
cantaloupe in his mouth repeat an entire
cantaloupe it's a 23-16 let's move oh in
this town anything is possible ghosts
zombies could be months before we find
our first clue hey look four seconds
that's weird they've got a hole in them
and they're leading to
oh this is an axe wait a minute the
lumberjack of course
in your face
nah it's too easy we're heading into
town right now to interrogate the
murderer seems like the kind of thing a
responsible parent wouldn't want you
doing good thing i'm an uncle avenge me
kids
this is the place
skull fracture
we don't
[Laughter]
stupid
where were you last night punching the
clock you were at work no i was punching
that clock
ten o'clock the time of the murder
so i guess you've never seen this before
listen little girl
that axe it's left-handed i only use my
right hand the manly
[Laughter]
three four five six huh
your wife is gonna be beautiful yes
but will she love me
she'll love you don't worry buddy that
means all we got to do is find our
left-handed suspect and we've got our
killer
huh
oh free pizza guy
[Music]
it's definitely that guy toby determined
you're under arrest for the murder of
the wax body of grunkle stan gobbling
goose feathers i don't understand
grunkle stan's new attraction would be
the story that saved your failing
newspaper but when the show was a flop
you decided to go out and make your own
headline
hey that's clever all the clues pointed
to a shabby shoot reporter ah
the shoe boy your little knees must be
sore from jumping to conclusions
i had nothing to do with that murder
then where were you the night of the
break-in
oh no cardboard cut out of female news
reporter chandra menace
hey i got a headline for you city kids
waste everyone's time
boy i'd be pretty embarrassed
kids
zeus
lifeless wax figures thank you all for
coming
one of the wax figures did it maybe the
shoe has a hole in it maybe whack stan
cut his own head off i'm sorry i got
glitter in my eye
wax stan's shoe has a hole in it all the
wax guys have that
maybe you're right
what has holes in its shoes and no
fingerprints mabel the murderers are
standing right behind yes
yes black sherlock holmes
clark shakespeare
wax coolio it is
congratulations my two amateur sleuths
you've unburied the truth and now we're
going to bury you
wow
bravo dipper pines you've discovered our
little secret said john oliver
applaud sarcastically
how is this possible you're made of wax
are you magic
we're cursed
cursed to come to life whenever the moon
is waxing
a haunted garage sale son
coolio's not dead
terrible price
20
i'll just take him when you're not
looking what i said i was gonna rob you
but when your uncle went to sleep we
would rule the night hey i told you to
stop that make me
it's like not at the museum it was a
charmed life for us cursed beings
that is until your uncle closed up shock
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
zeus what did you do
but we got the wrong guy
[Laughter]
so you were trying to murder grunkle
stan for real you were right all along
dipper wax people are creepy enough
now that you know our secrets you must
die
that's it we can melt them with hottie
melty things you really think you can
defeat us
i'm not really sure
attack
oh
interview this larry king
my neck my beautiful neck
jeff's on you groucho i've heard about a
cutting remark but this is ridiculous
hey why is there nothing in my hand
[Laughter]
because it's the disney channel other
than the
uh i don't know uh jin dynasty
all right let's get this taken care of
oh might just sneak up behind him
[Music]
mystery hack any last words
he got any sunscreen got any
what
[Music]
no outsmarted by a child in short pants
you know any limericks uh
there once was a dude from kentucky nope
you're okay you solved the mystery after
all i couldn't have done it without my
sidekick no offense dipper but you're
the sidekick what says who are people
saying that have you heard that
solve the case yet boy i'm so confident
you're gonna say no that i'm gonna take
a long slow sip for my cup of coffee
actually the answer is yes
oh no
oh god
99 sure that i did good enough for me
[Music]
no
so you're a rat tell me about that hey
get back here
larry king did guest star hey
wow they got a big old
guest cast for this episode i caught his
name
yeah did you catch his name i didn't
catch his name because you
are the sidekick i
caught john oliver's name so shut up oh
yeah so everyone's on the lookout for
who do you play sherlock holmes
wow
wow if that wasn't obvious enough as it
is i know was it really coolio did
either of us catch coolio it was cool
i don't know i'm not gonna look it up
let's assume it was
it's caught oh no
no your hair was perfect today unlike
yesterday
when it rained
when the rain falls down
yeah that was good man it's fun delight
very uh
house of wax
meets goosebumps meets night at the
museum
reminded me a lot of that twilight zone
episode where the guys got the wax
figures of all the famous killers and
then they spoilers
turn out to be killers
it's pretty sick
what the hell is the toilet oh dude
jordan peeled
yeah yeah it's called timing uh yeah it
was fun that was fun mm-hmm
after the three it wasn't my favorite
really why what's type 2
deep dive understanding why
although there were some really truly
funny moments yeah i kind of i would
have been vine with the wax reveal
earlier on and then just doing that yeah
the whole time because that's when it
really clicked with the fun yeah like
the investigation of the town was fun
but it was like we know something
supernatural is amongst us so let's just
get to it
and it didn't come into like the 15
minute mark yeah sounds like most of the
way through the episode yeah actually
could have had more fun with it instead
of a reveal that was a little
predictable
but when it showed up i mean it was like
such a cool concept and i like like the
visuals of it like the melting and then
when they do like the flashbacks it has
that like ghostly horror tale you know
what this show kind of reminds me of it
just hit me right now um
what is
you know i have no
specific title or description
in mind
uh eerie indiana you know those like 90s
video games when you're like teenagers
with like super soakers fighting zombies
or something like what i don't i don't
even know if that's an actual game but
that's what it's
like kind of like a harder core game but
it's sort of at a teenage level where
it's more fun
characters with backpacks yeah yeah like
kids you fight supernatural it has that
it has yeah like skateboards they use as
weapons yeah yeah like those arcades
yeah it's a bit of the vibe that i get
from this show
um
grunkle stan he i mean i thought we set
up a mystery with him in the pilot that
he knows more than he's letting on yeah
and we still haven't really touched on
that no i'm waiting for the show's
serialized elements to kick in does it
become serialized is that what was
teased in the comments i forget what you
guys said in the comments and i was like
oh that sounds cool oh i'm not sure
maybe maybe it is sort of sprinkled in
throughout the season or something but
yeah if that means this episode didn't
seem really interested in that at all
well i mean this one just gives you more
of the the town flair and the
city characters you might actually
explore a little bit more yeah and i
mean we saw like the lumberjack in the
previous episode and some of the other
characters around so i imagine they like
that could be cool too is having sort of
an ensemble who doesn't really always
appear because that's not always the
point but that can still kind of create
this idea that oh yeah like like you
would in a small town you know kind of
the
like the the old man comes back the
crazy old man and all that like you know
you have a sort of roster of characters
you know sure sure that could aid in the
sort of scooby-doo-ness of it too the
scooby-doo this crap that's crap
which is it yeah almost spoiled i know i
wanna remember no way on spider-man no
way because that line is slightly
differently different which which nobody
could have predicted from the trailer
but yeah scooby-doo this crap
yeah yeah that was uh but it was still a
little fun episode i like i like when it
really commits to the horror stuff yeah
when it when it reminds you like oh yeah
this is a show that's sort of aimed at
like
tween and young teenagers
not just like young kids so like yeah
when it's like
you die you know it's like oh dang we're
just gonna go there the guy's doing a
cardboard yeah he's being a real creeper
on that cardboard cutout i mean he dude
people don't even know about all the
cardboard cutouts i have of other
youtubers that i don't know dude phillip
defranco that one is
h3h you don't want to touch either of
those
rich evans from red letter media yeah
definitely sean evans for first hot ones
yeah
that's all that's all there is really
yeah i'm kidding definitely female ones
that's gross that's inappropriate we
want a mr beast one from that squid game
video yeah i'm giving away all these
cardboards
and they're all printed on money which
is now useless
yeah
so yeah that's that's a pretty mature
joke but i like stupid hillbilly cops
you know
uh i i uh
i've never been to a biker bar go we
should go and then vlog you should vlog
it i'm sure they'll go great yeah i've
never been to a biker bar but they are
always portrayed like these scuzzy
slimy everyone's beating each other up
yes kind of bar i wonder if that's true
there was a specific joke formation that
was occurring for a while
where it was just
calling it as it is i don't know what
the
what the term of type of joke that is
well like head chin
yeah yeah yeah that really like blunt
again i don't know what to call it the
the joke where you're just pointing out
what it is yeah yeah yeah instead of
like coming up with something funny
about it yeah what is that kind of humor
called
i don't know if you would call that dada
cause like it's kind of dumb you know
it's like it's dumb and it's on the nose
blunt
because yeah i don't know what it is
it's like done in a charming way because
yeah it's it's like all these things
you're used to seeing usually much more
interesting simplified to their basest
chin head neck
yeah you know yeah yeah hat
yeah like a free pizza guy yeah yeah if
there's a term for that please leave it
below because i am particularly tickled
by things like that and like in this
episode both of them got me pretty good
and they're like well placed it's like a
fourth really direct fourth wall joke
yeah they were doing a lot of them in a
row yeah and a lot of we don't serve to
minors yeah
and then they had the miner there yeah
and then they're terrible fake ids
they're good at putting in like
crafty little wordplay i love the
groucho marks like hey why why isn't
there anything in my hand
because like obviously they can't put a
cigar on disney xd yeah yeah like you
know these which isn't even a play on
words but yeah they they have a lot of
nice like uh
wordy humor
you see i would have liked more of those
wax people just to specifically hang out
more with those guys yeah and to like
relish in the guest voices and whatnot
and i mean i am a so i decided to give a
lot to larry king yeah cause kids love
larry king
yeah
teenagers they do
and they love coolio too they all still
remember coolio
but uh
i mean i i'm a sucker for a good living
wax figure story anyway so yeah like the
more of that the the better in my eyes
and i'm kind of sad that grunkle stan
well i i guess it would be a whole other
episode's worth of
conundrum but you know grunkle stan's
wax figure never had a chance to come to
life that we but they i mean there's
rules though established
oh did i me how did they become alive
i mean that sarcastically there's rules
okay they're at a haunted wax museum
where they come from that they were
purchased from okay because of that all
right
it's not just like any wax figure
otherwise the world would be run by wax
paper i don't know why i assumed that if
it was forged in the sort of general
vicinity of all the haunted wax figures
they might have some residual haunted
juju
oh yeah but yeah that makes that makes
sense you gotta pay attention i don't
know
yeah i know i'm gonna have a notepad out
next
episode i'm going to get one of those
the direct jokes that that joke was
particularly funny though
of like i'm just gonna i'm just gonna
take them when you're not looking what i
said i'm gonna rob you
a funny joke yeah yeah and
you're just wondering because it's not
really they're really the jokers uh uh
i'll get you the money later or some
other like
really bad way of lying yeah don't like
the delivery is i'm a terrible liar and
they're falling for it and
yeah so i appreciate it just
because becomes more direct
yeah no there's some really charming
little little character bits and uh yeah
i guess the the charm of the other two
episodes that i like is when they give
them a little bit extra layer to the
character yeah
um but i guess it has the heart of them
bonding at the end but like the last one
you you see that grunkle stan has more
of a
heart than you might expect yeah the
first episode was the brother and sister
coming together
and then they ran out of arcs not just
to make sure that we could
forget what grunkle stan might know or
not know
uh yeah all right guys well this is fun
thanks for being here make sure to
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button last but not least
scuba steve scuba listen if there's
anyone i would make a wax
figure out of it would be you because
let's face it
that would just be so damn sexy we'd add
an s on to there sexy scuba steve and
you know what we do we put scuba steve
in scoopy gear as well and then he would
come to life because you're a horror
fanatic then you would go around
murdering everyone who i possibly showed
the slightest interest into platonically
speaking because you would be filled
with envy and you'd want all my
undivided attention and you'd be doing
this behind my back and then when you
would reveal your true colors
guess what i'm all for it baby i would
have gone through with it from the
beginning you would never have to have
gone behind my back you should just come
forward i would have been like all i've
ever wanted is scuba diving sexy super
steep
but now you kill my mom so i gotta kill
you now oh i said you finally crushed me
why steve that's not platonic at all
merry christmas merry christmas you're
filthy
[Music]